hello everyone and welcome back to the
World Chess Championship match between
Yani ponachi and dinglier and we are in
Game 12 and it is uh incredible it is
absolutely incredible that Jan is
leading by a full point and the game
that just happened uh for those of you
who haven't seen it I'm once again
jealous uh because what you will now
experience will I don't know it will
completely change your your day your
week your month it will be uh well a
life-changing and for those of you who
don't want to see too many variations
who just are interested in the moves
because I have no idea how many lines
I'm going to cover here there will be a
section uh uh you know in in the
chapters you can check it out where I
will just show the moves but let's check
out the game now and see what happened
here so I know you guys enjoy me uh
showing uh who who played the first
moves so this gentleman here uh dimash
kudai Bergen uh he's a world-renowned
Kazakh singer a composer and the
multi-instrumentalist whatever whatever
it is I guess he can handle multi
multiple instruments at once or maybe
not at once but okay and he made the the
first ceremonial move of game 12. so
there you have it both players eager to
get on with the show and ding once again
opens with Pawn to D4 now uh we've
already seen what happened in one game
where Dean played Ponte for the Dead
game six where Dean went for the uh
London system and it was an absolute
Masterpiece but here we have Knight to
F6 Knight to F3 D5 and now everyone was
thinking okay will ding actually repeat
the London system uh no he plays Pawn to
E3 he goes for the call system uh and
this is now uh very very different it's
a quiet opening but it can also get very
loud as you'll see later on so here a
nice principle C5 and now Knight B to D2
this is somewhat rare but it has been
used by an incredibly strong player a
former world champion Vladimir kramnik
was known to play this uh Knight beat
the D2 line so see characters and D4 we
have e characters and queen to C7 again
sort of an offbeat idea by nepo uh C3
and now Bishop to D7 and already maybe
not a completely new move but it hasn't
been seen in any uh top tier games there
is one game between Gustafson and you
support that ended in a draw uh but
other than that no notable games so here
uh the idea probably is that uh as
everyone was pretty bedazzled by this
bishop to D7 move the idea is that if
you play Bishop G4 then white will play
Bishop to B5 check so by playing Bishop
to D7 uh Fabiano Corona said that maybe
this is uh sort of waiting for white to
develop the the lights were Bishop
somewhere else and then you can always
put the blush fungi for later on and
maybe the loss of a Tempo will not be
such a big deal so Bishop to D3 Knight
to C6 and now castles and indeed uh
neponagos for Bishop to G4 uh we have
Rook D1 by ding Ponte E6 and now just a
nice Knight to F1 and now you can
challenge the bishop later on maybe H3
Bishop to H5 maybe then it comes to G3
and so on pretty standard stuff here so
here Bishop to D6 and now Bishop to G5
putting pressure on the
uh Knight here and uh nepo just castles
here and well you could also consider
Castle in Queen side nipple castles King
side and he once again invites ding to
mess up his Pawn structure ding already
tried that once and nipple completely
crushed him if you remember he uh
doubled the Rooks on the G file and the
ding could not survive the attack and
the situation on the clock here uh an
hour and 25 for Ding and an hour and 38
for Nepal so Nepal again uh playing much
much faster uh and here Bishop captures
an F6 you could consider some other
moves like Ponte H3 or maybe just a nice
winning move but ding goes for it he
wants to open up the black king and go
for the attack G captures an F6 and
knights the G3 and now uh all sorts of
uh things can go wrong here uh here in
the game the immediate F5 was played but
let's say nipple play something like
King th8 then you run into lines like
Ponte H3 Bishop captures Queen captures
and if F5 you can even play Knight
captures on F5 and after let's say
captures captures threatening Checkmate
F6 defending checkmate and now you can
play some like Rook D6 you don't even
have to capture the D5 Pawn right away
you can now threaten this Pawn you're
threatening this Pawn you still have
this pressure on H7 you can prepare to
bring the other Rook into the game so
it's a pretty pretty crazy position and
you you've grabbed uh plenty of pawns
for that sacrifice piece you will grab
another one so perfectly fine nipple
does not like the look of this he plays
F5 right away and now we have Ponte H3
and he goes Bishop captures on F3 uh the
problem is uh he made a little pause
here and the pause was he was
calculating uh Pawn to F4 and it's a
fine move to make uh point being that
after let's say you play H Captain G4
and captures on G3 there's Dev captors
and G3 and Bishop captures and G3 the
problem is after this F4 move uh ding
doesn't have to go into this capture
Fest you can just play Knight to F1 okay
now he does vacate the H5 Square for the
bishop but now it's in Knight one to H2
and it's um you know it's fine for both
the nipple loses this diagonal but he
does get to keep this bishop on this
diagonal so it's a it's a trade-off but
nipple decided to trade immediately he
played Bishop captures on F3 Queen
characters and now Knight D7 preparing
to bring the Knight to G6 with Knight to
H5 by Ding King to h8 and now Pawn to G4
dingos for it he's going all out he
needs the win with the white pieces to
equalize the match and then add the two
uh games that are remaining will give us
uh uh the the new world champion and how
can nipple continue here uh there are
many good candidate moves uh I will just
show you one uh Knight to G6 in the game
nipple played Rook to Jade but Knight to
G6 is so rich for example G captures on
F5 Knight to H4 attacks the White Queen
Queen E3 and now Rook to G8 check into
H1 and Rook to G2 uh what is uh what is
happening here look at this queen to H6
going
uh for Queen to F6 check now Rook the HD
with checkings you want you bring the
other Rook into the game as well King to
F1 and now Bishop p7 you stop Queen to
F6 and black is just winning uh there's
um no good way to uh to handle this uh
this is not a fourth line entirely uh
but it was a pretty pretty good try now
the problem is if Pawn to F6 you have
Knight the F5 attack the queen and once
the queen moves you want to trade queens
now you just bring the bishop back
Bishop to D6 and the ones the queen
moves because there are no good squares
now you just play Rook G to G2 and this
is now resigns for white uh because
whatever playlist the bishop captures it
there's this nasty Queen to see for
check and that's a huge a huge problem
let's say Bishop the D3 Rook captures an
F2 check if King to G1 you're just gonna
play root captures on D2 and at the end
of the day uh White will be up um uh to
uh not too much material but the white
king will be uh completely lost here you
will soon get checkmated or or you will
suffer severe material material loss so
that's kind of the uh the option of
going with Knight to G6 but it's not
completely forced however it would be
hard to defend nipple instead goes Rook
to G8 King uh ding plays King to H1 and
now Knights the G6 so similar not quite
the same and Bishop the C to a very
weird move by Ding and it can be
explained by uh by the potential of
black playing F4 the problem is if you
play Rook to G1 let's say and now comes
Knight to H4 where do you move the queen
you can't move the queen to D3 You're
Gonna Play Queen E3 and now maybe F4 and
this is very annoying so that's why ding
first played Bishop to C2 and now if
that happens he will always have the D3
Square for his Queen so it does happen
Knight to H4 Queen to E3 and now nepo
decides against Ponte for now the queen
coming to D3 could in fact be pretty
good yeah so uh and but it's not it's
nothing spectacular okay you're
threatening Checkmate Rook Rook G6 will
stop Checkmate very nicely but instead
after this queen T3 moved we have rooked
the G6 right away by nipple Rook to G1
and only Now Pawn to F4 now it's not
such a big deal Queen to D3 and now
Queen to E7 here there are many uh many
lines many forcing lines indeed uh I
will just show uh Pont F5 because it's
kind of relevant for the game uh now how
do you how do you deal with this let's
say Pawn to F3 Rook 8 to G8 very nice by
black and now let's say Rook 8 to F1
okay uh the the white can hold but it's
uh again a very very good for black but
after Queen to D3 nepo played Queen to
E7 and now comes Rook 8 to E1 uh by uh
by ding the problem is you could play G5
it looks like a really scary move of
course The Rook cannot capture due to
Checkmate and uh how do you handle this
uh the problem is there's Ponte H6 and
now it's actually perfectly fine G
captures Rook captures now you are
guarding Checkmate from here uh and if
Bishop to D1 to to guard the Knight then
you play rotate the G8 and black is
black is extremely well prepared here
black will be well even much better so
instead after Queen t7 Rook 8 to E1 by
Bing and now comes Queen to G5 by nipple
uh now he has all sorts of ideas maybe
Pawn to F3 maybe the Knight comes to G2
maybe the Knight just moves then the
queen comes to H4 then Queen captures an
H3 at some point uh so looking very
scary that being played uh Pawn to C4 uh
and not the captures on C4 with Queen to
C3 aligning the queen nicely with the
King on this diagonal and nipple just
played Pawn to B5 and everyone started
celebrating here this was a moment of
true celebration for the chest world
because this is a uh sort of a double
exclamation mark move when you make a
really good move you get an exclamation
mark when you make a spectacular move
you get two exclamation marks and this
is um what nipple was awarded by the
interface and the point is now that D5
doesn't really do all that much Ponte
live and you you have no problems here
you defend the C4 Pawn there are no
issues here and you don't really care
about Bishop captures and G6 now here
Ponte A4 was played of course Dean wants
to challenge this structure and now
again everyone was expecting Point A6
you're kind of used to seeing this idea
when B5 is played a challenger with A4
it pawn A6 displayed and now after let's
say captures captures and B3 Rook to C8
and now let's say uh coppers captors
Queen to B3 uh and now the game just
continues
um uh you can play Queen to D3 it'd be
great if you could but Queen D5 check
and you just lose there's no defense
against this you don't have a good
cover-up here and if you block with
something like Queen T four dangerous
root captures on C2 uh will blunder a
piece so yeah so there's that however
nipple played Pawn to B4 here he started
playing very quickly and it's uh uh you
know an admirable idea just giving up
the C4 Pawn like that the point is the
queen captures on C4 and now nipple
plays a rook 8 the G8 it and he was
definitely on to something it's just
that Rook 8 to G8 is not that on to
something more that I was referring to
the the OMG line is actually Knight to
F3 uh not because you're going after
material the point is that after Queen
to C6 attacking the Knight and the Rook
here there's Knight captures and he won
Queen characters and A8 and now uh after
Rook to J challenging the queen queen
goes back to E4 threatens Checkmate uh
uh not um uh right away but uh right
away but Knight captures on C2
eliminates Checkmate Queen captures and
now Queen to H4 going after the pawn
here Queen to D3 defending and now Pawn
to F5 it's it's a really big huge uh uh
you know line but uh it just works Queen
to F3 F captures Rook captures on G4 and
now Rook captures on G4 uh Queen
characters and G4 you trade everything
and it seems like you just traded down
into an equal end game but there's spawn
to B3 and this is the move that you you
have to see all the way back in order to
find the winning idea now there is no
defense against Bishop to A3 absolutely
stunning Knight to F6 Bishop to A3 and
that's it you can stop the pawn it's not
that you can't stop the pawn is just
that black will take too much material
while you are you know on your on your
way to stop the fall night cap for some
B3 Bishop captures on F2 you're up two
points of course uh completely winning
for black so Knight to F3 uh was the
move that uh should have been celebrated
here but Rook 8 to G8 was played by nepo
uh and now ding plays Queen to C6 Queen
to D3 a much safer choice but he goes
for Queen to C6 he wants to keep an eye
on this diagonal now stopping any Knight
to F3 ideas uh but now uh nepo played
Bishop to B8 and again a critical line
to consider is Knight to F5 uh I will
just show it because it's uh it's uh
remarkable how do you continue the game
if you play something like Bishop
captures on F1 then you get e captures
on F5 and now after let's say Rook 38
okay you trade first you cap after on G4
and afterward captures on G8 King
captures Queen to E8 with Chuck Bishop
to f8 and now Queen to E5 you offer
Queen trade but Queen H4 and uh chances
are uh White will not be able to survive
this it's a very very difficult position
to play Maybe with you know uh engine
precise play but not very likely uh the
other thing is if you don't capture here
uh what are your other options you can
play Rook to D1 uh just um you know wait
and see what happens but then the
immediate Queen to H4 so you can't
really do this if Queen to F3 there's
Knights the G3 check blocking the
Queen's path to the defense of the H3
pawn and now if Ro captures if F
captures of course then you just play
Queen captures on H3 so here F captures
and G3 let's say Bishop captures and G6
Queen characters and H3 with check King
to G1 even capture on F2 with King
captures and now uh sorry uh King
characters now Queen captures an F3 with
check King captures and now if captures
on G6 leaves you with position being up
upon so Knight to F5 uh great for black
however didn't continues but never
played Rook the bishop to B8 and now we
have Queen to B7
here I'm just going to show one other
very very impressive line because uh
here instead of Queen to B7 ding had the
option of going for Bishop captures on
G6 and the point it's so strong is not
because you you win material this game
started being about a material a long
long time ago the point is that after
each captures on G6 there's D5 you open
up uh this uh dark diagonal and now
there's uh no good move here if you play
Queen captures on D5 you just trade
because you are already a material
characters captures let's say Knight to
F6 and the white is up too much material
you you're up the exchange you're gonna
collect the pawns uh this is game over
uh the other thing after D5 let's say
you play e captures on D5 uh Knight to
F6 that's the star move and now the Rook
will be uh just harassed Rook the fade
Queen C5 attacks The Rook Rook to d8
Queen to E7 and now you move the Rook
you lose the F7 pawn and the black's
position collapses uh but okay uh both
of them are playing very quickly there
are getting lower and lower on time
being played Queen to B7 win for the F7
pawn and now Rook to H6 by nipple uh
just uh inviting ding to capture that
opponent F7 but you can't really do it
if you if you capture it there's no
follow-up there's no threat here and
Knight to F3 still exists so instead
after this Rook to H6 move uh we have
Bishop to E4 biting just stabilizing the
position now gaining more control over
this diagonal keeping the keeping around
the Knight and the situation on the
clock is 23 minutes for Ding and 35 SEC
minutes for Nepal minutes so here Rook
the f8 Nepal just defends the the pawn
here even though again the tricky move
will spawn to F3 uh I know I'm showing a
lot of lines here but there it's such a
rich position like font F3 if Queen
captures an F7 now you play Knight to G2
you go after the rook and now white must
part with the Rook the problem is if you
move the Rook somewhere let's say Rook
C1 Knight F4 and you cannot defend this
position now uh the the white will no
longer be able to defend along the H
file and that's it even if Bishop
captures an F3 are going to capture an
H3 and it's just terrible terrible for
white but instead after Bishop to E4
Rook the f8 was played nemojo's defense
df7 Pawn remember nepo is still leading
the match he just needs a rock he
doesn't want to over complicate if dim
wants to burn time to find the winning
idea he can do so here uh Queen captures
on B4 then just call it just collects a
pawn and now if nepo doesn't have some
sort of a Checkmate the ding will just
even push B4 B5 A5 B6 create a pass pawn
and you know could pose more problems so
here Queen back to d8 and now comes
Queen to C3 the problem is if if D5
right away and you really want to play
this move then E5 closes this and then
F5 comes at some point so it's very
strong by playing Queen to C3 you're
just waiting for Nepal to make a move
and you're sort of inviting him to play
F5 if he plays F5 you can play Bishop to
C6 and then D5 will be
uh sort of a a problem uh so after Queen
to d8 like I said Queen to C3 was played
now comes Knights the G6 by an EPO 18
minutes here on the clock for for ding
uh 24 minutes for Yan uh ending plays
Bush of the back to G2 here F3 again you
you want to stop a Black's F3 attempt at
some point but the include Bishop to G2
he just wants to add more support here
uh and Jan now plays the immediate Queen
to H4 we have rooked the E2 guarding the
F2 pawn and now uh now comes the the
Magic Moment the situation on the clock
is very uh tricky it's like 15 minutes
for ding like 24 minutes for nepo uh and
here you could consider a lot of moves
you can consider more like Rook to G8
you could consider more like Queen to G5
uh you could consider a move like a
bishop to D6 so all uh basically waiting
moves to see what the ding will uh try
try and come up with but the move that
nepo played uh is uh impossible to
explain as especially since this is a
classical game this is a World Series
championship match and this is something
uh this is what you would call if it was
not a world championship match what you
would call A Classic nipple move he
played Ponte F5 and now uh it's it's a
move that was great in pretty much every
position so far and even winning in some
but here it just wanders the game away
so feel free to pause the video and try
and spot what nipple missed while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh well maybe maybe the greatest blunder
ever in a World Chess Championship match
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Rook captures on E6
this is what nepo missed he completely
blundered the pawn here and it's not
just that he blundered upon he's now
down two pawns but his position is
completely dead he has no counter play
he has no attack he has no follow-up uh
he has no answer to pawn to D5 this is a
completely unplayable and basically Jan
spent uh 20 minutes here just waiting uh
you know uh probably preparing for for
the press conference you know thinking
about all the questions so they will ask
him how to explain how how to calm down
how not to maybe be overly rude uh
because this is this is pure pain we've
seen pain uh in In This World Series
Championship we've seen pain in other
words championships but this is I don't
know this is pure pain this is like uh
from from winning the equal to sort of
finish the equalish the
like one of the worst blunders you you
could ever commit uh and in fact it was
in this position on move 35 that Ian
pomnishi resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here there is
no coming back from this there is no
reply on to D5 whatever playlist upon to
F3 you challenge the bishop here just D5
check and if you Bishop to E5 you attack
the queen not a problem Rook captures on
E5 and if let's say F characters on G2
check you even just capture it it's you
know not a problem you're threatening to
move the Rook for some nasty Discovery
so King the G8 and now Rook to E6 yeah
or pretty much any other move any move
is winning here for why this is not some
sort of uh you know exclusive winning
Line This is just moving pieces because
every move is winning here let's say you
play Rook to F7 you have to stop
Checkmate uh but just Rook d8 with check
now again if you move the Rook it's
Checkmate so you have to uh block with
the Knight let's say Knight to f8 now
comes G captures an F5 check and the
black king is out of squares now you're
gonna have to start giving even more
material and this is just sad to watch
this is really sad and I you know I I'm
very very sad for nepo that it came to
this and then and that he for the third
time in the match blundered his uh one
point lead but I'm also very happy for
doing that he was able to bounce back
and what this means for the match is
that either we get one more decisive
game and then another decisive game and
then we go into rapid tie breaks maybe
even Blitz tie breaks uh or uh you know
we just get to do calm games and then we
still go into tie breaks because whoever
becomes the champion uh although I I
would want the world classes
Championship to be decided in a
classical match you know over the course
of let's say 14 classical games I
wouldn't mind an extra day of uh you
know some some rapid chess as those
games I believe will be absolutely
spectacular uh and here uh I I also have
this this is a nepo after he made that
root captures an E6 move he basically
made it left the board and then only
went after when he came back he saw what
he did and he couldn't believe it uh one
of the possibilities is that because of
this road captures a uh an E6 move maybe
he was considering a move like Queen G5
or after this F1 maybe he was
considering Queen G5 and then maybe
after B4 now Ponte F5 but now uh it's a
little bit different now it's not the
same position maybe this is something he
was calculating let's say root captures
an E6 now we have captors and G4 and
it's much much different if Pawn to D5
check then Bishop to E5 the position is
sufficiently defended and it's actually
black who is winning here so maybe this
is something that uh he was you know
discussing in his mind and then he
thought maybe as he was really blitzing
it out he was really just make a move
get out of the board come back make a
move get out of the board maybe he
thought he was in this line in the queen
G5 line and then you know if if a move
happens then uh five then it makes sense
then the E6 spawn is off limits but that
was not the case the reality is that uh
the queen is still on H4 he played at 5
and that's it uh so yeah this is the the
clip I wanted to show you this is Nepal
after he made the move uh you know just
pure pain pure pain there is no other
way to describe it and he was pretty
much like this for some 20 minutes so it
was really really hard to watch uh but
yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it Game 12 of the World Chess
Championship match between Yani pomichi
and the dingler and ding now equalizes
the match and now the score is six to
six uh and we get we once again get a
match and uh I mean I I'm just happy I
know everyone is about happy and sad
that Magnus is not playing it's sort of
a
a mixed feeling situation because you
know you want magnets to be playing but
also you want to see games like this uh
so you know it's a it's a trade-off uh
but yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank ABC's
of chess for kids Barry mcmurdock Alec
Rose Moon uh Kim Tori Jensen and jack
obied for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the World
Chess Championship Match until it
finishes uh thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and also yeah I forgot about just
the move so now for those of you who
don't really have the time to check out
the game these are the moves it was the
call system uh young played this uh
Queen to C7 line which is somewhat rare
uh we had this position uh Jan allowed
his Pawn structure to be doubled
captures captures and captures didn't
win for the attack broke the G8 uh uh
this is okay all very standard stuff
just pushing F4 Now The Rook can't move
because of Checkmate on H7 and here here
nipple played this spectacular B5 move
which is a double exclamation mark move
A4 now comes upon to B4 uh Queen
captures and here we have this beautiful
position where after Bishop T4 and Rook
to f8 uh you get this position Bishop G2
Queen H4 rook and now Ponte F5 and with
pontef I mean this position which can
still be played in many other way many
many different ways Nepal play Ponte F5
and he completely blundered uh ding
played Rook captures on E6 uh and he was
in this position that Jan resigned
because there is no counter play
whatever he does uh just loses let's say
F3 you open up this diagonal uh
threatened check and now well let's say
anything now Checkmate is being
threatened and now you just play
something like this you open up a check
and the black resigns there are no more
squares for the king you have to start
giving up material so that's the short
version if you by any chance have the
time for the longer version I do
recommend it go to the beginning of the
video uh thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day